on va poursuivre avec alain gravel de
l'émission enquête qui connaît très bien
le dossier de l'hiver tu alain au-delà
des recommandations et aussi le ton de
ce rapport on sent une certaine
frustration de la part du corniaud de
l'âge un homme qui maintenant à plus de
80 ans qui mène ce métier depuis presque
50 ans qui a amené 500 enquêtes du
coroner un de ses plus gros sur 45 un
incendie à notre dame du lac dans une
autre résidence pour personnes âgées
tout près de l'île verte dans le
témiscouata 44 victimes et 45 ans plus
tard le dépôt de son rapport et on
retrouve quoi dans ce rapport une
citation qui a attiré mon attention
lorsqu'il dit j'ai beaucoup de
difficulté à accepter au cours de la
présente enquête j'ai rencontré les
mêmes obstacles que j'avais noté il ya
près de vingt ans lors d'une série d'
enquête que j'avais tenu dans des
résidences pour personnes âgées donc on
n'a pas beaucoup changé en fait ce qu'il
dit c'est que il note des problèmes qui
reviennent par exemple manque de
préparation manque de formation des
pompiers bâtiment qui correspond plus ou
moins aux normes un laxisme ou si des
autorités politiques qui se traîne les
pieds pour qu'on prenne au sérieux
l'importance de mettre sur pied des
services des 110 professionnels et
sécuritaire dans les petites localités
et alors que dans un contexte où une loi
existe maintenant depuis quinze ans une
loi qui devait régler les problèmes dans
les régions pour les services incendie
bon vous avez fait plusieurs enquêtes
sur vous avez mené plusieurs enquêtes
sur les vertes est ce qu'il ya des
choses qui se retrouve donc dans ce
rapport est-ce que ça fait écho à ce que
vous avez trop oui notamment on avait
diffusé avant le début de l'enquêté du
coroner on avait diffusé un reportage on
parlait des retards d'intervention
importants et surtout du retardement de
demander l'entr'aide des villages
avoisinants ce qui fait que il ya eu de
longues minutes qui se sont perdus et
qui a probablement aggraver la situation
on a parlé aussi dans ce reportage je
manque d'informations de tous les
officiers de du service incendie de
l'île verte on a parlé aussi des ratés
dans l'intervention notamment l'absence
de poste de commandement sur place qui
fait que lorsque impact pas de
commandement les pompiers sont un peu
comme des poules pas de tête il est le
corner de l'âge parle dans son rapport
dix dans son rapport aujourd'hui que
lorsque ça arrive les profits pour
davantage partie du problème que de la
solution bon il maintenant sur cette
fameuse clause grand père sur la
formation des pompiers on en a beaucoup
parlé il reste assez prudent quand même
en fait de ne pas ils déplorent
l'existence de cette clause grand père
je vous rappelle que par exemple dans le
code du vent charron le chef à l'île
verte ou d'autres chefs si vous étiez
chef avant 1998 donc avant l'adoption de
la loi vous pouvez rester chef sans
avoir la formation requise par la loi ce
qui donc c'est une exception alors le
coroner déplorent l'existence toujours
de cette clause mais il reste prudent
parce qui sait très bien que s'ils
demandent ou si le gouvernement
interdit ou met fin à cette exception du
jour au lendemain mais il risque d'avoir
un départ très important de nombre très
important de d'officier ou de pompiers
au québec et vous savez les pompiers
volontaires c'est très difficile de
concilier la fonction de pompier le
travail parce que ce sont des gens qui
travaillent à temps plein et la
formation parce que lorsque vous faites
cette formation vous la fait qu'un le
soir ou les fins de semaine c'est pour
toujours évident ça peut prendre un peu
plus de temps tout à fait merci beaucoup
alain